qu'est ce qu'on cherche si à stopper la
pandémie on cherche à ce que nous
n'ayons pas cette croissance chez pai a
réussi à les stratosphérique
méfions-nous des mots mais on a un sujet
de santé publique qui touche notamment
les jeunes mais qui met en péril un
certain nombre de gens fragiles voilà
pourquoi le premier des sujets c'est la
vaccination vaccinez vous respectez les
gestes sanitaire notre notre succès aux
élections régionales départementales
après le succès des municipales et des
sénatoriales
on crée des devoirs vis-à-vis des
français et nous savons que si nous
voulons offrir aux français une
véritable alternative démocratique eh
bien ils nous faut un seul candidat et
nous avons acté ce principe nous avons
acté une procédure qui va nous conduire
avec un calendrier
s'il n'y a pas un candidat consensuel à
la fin du mois de septembre faire un
choix d'un processus de départage